Prince Harry has reportedly claimed that
he was physically confronted by his
brother William in a row over his
relationship with Meghan Markle well
those allegations are made in a leaked
copy of his new book which is set to be
published next week and seen by The
Guardian newspaper what's going to use
his approach Kensington Palace for a
response in the meantime let's talk to
our Royal correspondent Rhianna Mills
who joins me now so Rihanna some pretty
serious claims being reported today what
can you tell us about them
yeah so anticipation has really been
ramping up I think over the last few
months ahead of this book being released
we of course knew that the title was
going to be spare we've had that Netflix
docu-series and people have been
wondering exactly how far Prince Harry
would go when it came to to writing down
his Recollections and what he's wanted
to share but the the claims that we're
hearing from this leaked copy are quite
extraordinary when it comes to the
breakdown in the relationship that he
had with his brother now it's worth
saying that the book the review copies
aren't due out until Monday they're not
due to be released into the public until
Tuesday and yet the Guardians seem to
have had a copy in advance now I'll just
read you some of what it says in this
Guardian article in terms of this
altercation which it seems happened or
Prince Harry claims that happened back
in 2019 he says that it was all to do
with William basically calling Megan
abrasive rude and difficult he then
writes that William came into into their
home at Nottingham Cottage Harry gave
him a glass of water and said Willie I
can't speak to you when you're like this
Harry then writes he set down the water
called me another name then came at me
it all happened so fast so very fast he
grabbed me by the collar ripping my
necklace and he knocked me to the floor
I landed on the dog's bowl which cracked
under my back the pieces cutting into me
I lay there for a moment dazed then got
to my feet and told him to get out
now they are very serious allegations
this morning I have reached out to two
people at Kensington Palace for any
comments so far haven't heard anything
back from them we know that in 2019 that
relationship between the two brothers
was falling apart not simply because of
those leaked reports which Harry has
repeatedly talked about in the Netflix
documentary and these interviews that
are due to be released on Sunday with
likes of Anson Cooper for CBS and Tom
bradby for ITV
but also because Harry himself in a
documentary talked about how he wasn't
getting on with his brother so it's not
unexpected to hear that the brothers
were not getting on in 2019 but it is
shocking to be given this much personal
detail I think in the past there's been
criticisms of Harry that he's made some
some very damning allegations when it
comes to racism within the palace or
allegations that they weren't taking
Megan's mental health issues seriously
enough but there have been suggestions
that they haven't gone far enough in
naming specifics but it seems that Harry
in this book is not holding back